we have a title for the centenary  special  finally  good grief they're really withholding  information on this  power of the doctor  i don't love it  i mean like it's it's  fine  it's like it's both evoking power of the  daleks but also um feeling like it  rhymes with day of the doctor time of  the doctor night of the doctor etc etc  etc um so you know i see how they got  there  there's just implications with a title  like that  when you say something like the power of  the doctor and especially knowing that  it is intended to tie up the timeless  child plots  that really feels like it's going to  lean very heavily into all the stuff  that i hated about that idea and how  special it made the doctor into this  weird chosen one with unique abilities  that no other time lord has and i'm like  i  that's really not what i want but  that's the story that's left to tie up  so i can't say i'm surprised